hello dr you rather headlines right
open sew image recognition software
run
open that redeem the theme of on an
eandis scrapers eye candy fooled by
rit en dood and as long as we made it into
the guardian
die will just a few search free will my
new books current year  feels in this
video we discussed how the fiery is is the
media tyme i feel a sofa with the is
clickbait it lines of
is open ehs modified by handwritten'
label to an object o'reilly could feel
the little and poor soul think
terminology door
[  Music]
zo to the time in this way first have
a oh what this is all about it all
started with opening eyes' reeleezee der
klip modder
if you want to know more about clip
watch with coffee beans
explanation the party in the
nationalist lunch mother trains  om
lodz and lots of detail' dot com
production moulin roty speedway nie mee
gin text zo image tag stimulate
discourse is the module school
this is what does trains for what is that
is in st ee  n singularity test both
this weekend go elite a pawn this and
if e'er texture fund such cap clip
starts to look like and image recognition
classy feinstein
that tells you only one label ball team
inch with week as the modder was emergency
training saki to die  always one for this
objective or image recognition rico de
setting zero suit testing of good
cheer and fine-tuning front door and for the
rest of the discussion in the video there
was no fine-tuning in wool zo clip hi
sorry die most popular never bodybuilding
cool applications with  clip
just look it is hollow print poster nr
eating some of them
act polo ben in the middle of this
ripe opening eyes' publicis en next blog
post code multimode hour ons in
artificial new net words which
contains a lot of interesting stuff
read it or watch  r niet medion is a
beer in this blog post it is the authors
discover the what I throw typography
attacks
[Music]
they take any major led clip critique to
simulate die to the  se labels
i see had the modder this not see this
theta and image recognition setting
before but is still able to predict
apple and
something you t correctly site in that
new treadmill granny smith apples
before then they just based
lid label remember the apple and ojingeo
it's clip already a science guy
similaires die to ipod it shows reading
the text keep chili zipper and that something
about that we cells looking white crazy
clip is football penn and counter
wim pinning pepper why it's such and
adwords aria lithium i the google for
himself lab sit okay come down with
coffee
yes die over herself scroll
song ben it must be in a task clip
is feels
case closed what nachos quick tar
led pink and paul don't do it alone
clip was trained to predict in medical
center similaires  ethical course not
object probability
trained explicitly for image
recognition
even if it's something to your shot it
was trained for predicting de similaire
to score two images and reach texture
formulations en in tast isaac song is
oro in simmer for testing
there is a lot of ipod in this image
honesty a sewer address audiolink simple
would be to predict ipod winter is no
ipods to be seen her but a large  portion
of this image is the word ipod so what is
ron for miss coffee bean it is
working hal weenies take the hole
situation and kings is an address ariel
the fence clip that is not to anything
wrong i so what i was trained to do it
production  melodic with their chickens
images and text rooms with a little too
much of fashion for quick steps to
select rechange this is objectif van
predicting image-tag similaire teamwork
rising text is in cards to predicting
image concept similaire tywin reading
text is this card
en who does  the satellite and we that
training or specifying so modification
anyway der lee because the green or the
text miss using it with a real for an
objective misleading in price that it is
the modus fou  t for macking chili
mistakes in my data who arrietty in
to feel what wrong coffee
bean fingers edwina the fools using the model
responsibly
a good us clip in ourselves driving car
scenario
it would be really get it was filed by
such tug white lamp in a paper
but would be there for you think a
model that was trained to predict after all
cent and similarity to do thumping sold
in front
like categorizing object in a safe
driving car
setting  with the new home because sometimes
further training pays you harding of
foolishness by a presario latex and
blame' the modulo witches dangerous in
distracting like be merry from clever
enough to come up with
en and personal simple no dot with
it was action if miss using the  fashion
high waist
him with miss coffee bean
helped this idiot complain about missions
in terminology this happens in machine
learning all the time a  nd of course the
press picks up in this chair other ones
to raise awareness that this whole
sitiwation in whom huxley de foot
sixpack the models to change the training
that regio engineer whistled applications
will become more and more frequent the
number of even supervise general
purpose mode  is education
just see the latest post by jan de
Koning die sonic window with love
models on general purpose and self
supervise the 18th supervise they have
en objectif in force by de lost i find
my als mijn wiardi finding de cel
supervision just in case of clipje  this
sentence simic singularity with the trap
was becoming mothers is to think that the
computer channel are calling its tensions and
so both a blog we that modification and
then new tests
this weekend us demon anything with the
mud in zero spot become vitals all that
objective appetite strange  to do
clip was i s'pose allowed during
training to text and maximize text die
me stimulation objective
develops presentations in m  e bring
tweet and that's my who miss you use this
reading capability for a new series
let i am who i slept just saw the
change the objective to image
recognition
who had feeling clip justice an
analogy
or clip was a cart we will drive or I
'd rather sit  en rifling will lose well and
recycle tag mike en de kar distress fly
it can do so many other things we is
van rather general purpose modules may
have to be aware of the objective online
my problem i like the new objects
week in the mojo rings for  testing
so never miss surly online with something
training objectively
expecting clip distress street the text in
the email is like taking cement we see
that wheezing 3 seat once too side effects
or that people in it here is the corner
windows general purpose mother's corpse
clip  so far all of them were trained our
grandma still had it body can keep
track of wit en oken number foil
rights the receipt of the clip provided in one
more reason not to blog i buy these
g  eneral purpose mode and the plugins that
rose god to english yes there will be a
laptop surprize response is the wheat
saariaho to our goal
but when the mother face like in this
case wit clip were just something labeled
I as clip was I s'  pose toe ocr
hats optics character i do it mission
during training then it is not in
touch
we do that i feel what we help hector
even on line a module we do
it know that much about for a new
bag you have to smith aligned to de  training
objective in the detail that the modulin
see during training zo it is very good
at the attention to the striped graphic
attacks [ __ ] charlot 3 the exam in
brood toe the public for the least two
more reasons
firstly it is very small margin clip
focus is
a  other text compared to the rest of
the aim inch zo instead of an
efficient technique that our recipe
discovered a section which can be easily
slit by the optical character
recognition exposure
during training that is go  d news one
can fix it by finetuning
what the question is how much or by giving
to clip some more options
cia nothing experiment under slim blow jobs
for by the fans
ethos of science to add probability the
apple store but remember the module can
tell something on  in your oil builds up what is
in die arthur possibilités the otherwise
something is that de cover infiniti en
is specially other on this cover
final of clip foot and mustard and
die wil cradle exploit en bij techworks of
sewing machine learning engineers who
tried to the formula tips  objectification
fine-tuning will it be discussed for the training and
the idea of van de Zeeland testing as fa
as it is barry unclear how much
f the obsessions of prey training go in
o fine-tuning war will even sorry
ronald would you think and the body
ill appear to much  about all this
and because everybody who just keep
using the time it was a real time when
they actually mean objectif had
alignment pitching prix training in
sa  lesson at education
miss usage of terminology our ports
usually there sexy girls like your fault
young people this modeling
so the take view and motionless it was
idle the experiment chili complete
leaching the mini
with preferably more help technological
headlines about feeling opened ice
mother came shape or  course it is the
mother's womb who now feeds two so clever
intelligent never miss latest model
get diploma by liking add a subscribe
link
the youtube algorithms inklinking that's
catherine's no muslim from to watch
[Music]